hello everybody out there this is brock  favors with traffic on the ones chad  armstrong  is out sick today so i am filling in for  my usual land reports  and uh i'm up here in the chopper but i  gotta tell you guys i  am loving the view  all right well we are um uh  we are over the 10. it is massively  clogged down there like a pint of maple  syrup on a cool november morning  my god  okay okay i am uh  i am very sorry folks there's a little  bit of a bumpy ride up here  we are now approaching the 405 and where  the left lane is blocked by a mattress  so somebody is uh going to be doing a  little return to ikea later today  oh  i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm very sorry folks  i'm very sorry but but i'm losing my  head up here  actually you have every right too we're  about to crash  [Music]  you